[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en france24
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días comenzamos
con los populares los angoleños están
llamados a las urnas para las elecciones
generales uno de los principales temas
en juego es la situación económica del
país tras cinco años de recesión también
analizamos las elecciones presidenciales
en kenia el candidato raila odinga ha
impugnado los resultados y ha presentado
un recurso en la corte suprema- el
actual vicepresidente william bruto fue
declarado ganador con más del 50 por
ciento de los votos y terminamos esta
edición en colombia donde fue celebrado
el petronio un festival anual para
preservar conmemorar y honrar la
herencia y las tradiciones africanas en
colombia nuestra enviada especial le
ahora él estuvo allí
comenzamos en angola donde más de 14
millones de personas eligen a sus
diputados y a su presidente tras cinco
años de recesión por la caída del precio
del petróleo y la pandemia de corey 19
el país volvió a un relativo crecimiento
económico en 2021 pero el milagro
prometido por el presidente joão
lourenço está lejos de hacerse realidad
la economía del país está luchando por
diversificarse y el desempleo está en un
30 por ciento antes de analizar la
situación en el siguiente informe veamos
algunos datos generales sobre el país la
población angoleña de unos 33 millones
de personas es mayoritariamente
cristiana la capital del país es wanda y
el principal idioma que se habla es el
portugués
hace 5 años primo estás hija hizo una de
las mayores apuestas de su carrera el
propietario de varias tiendas y
restaurantes de luanda invirtió 75 mil
dólares en tu poca la primera empresa de
reparto a domicilio en angola hoy la
plataforma es un éxito con mil pedidos
al día y franquicias en toda la región
aquí problema horario últimamente
petróleo aquí más allá de los diamantes
y el petróleo todavía hay muchos
sectores en los que se puede invertir si
tienes una idea que aún no se ha
desarrollado aquí y que funciona bien en
otros lugares hay potencial para crear
un negocio
tú querías
ese negocio sin embargo este potencial
no se ha aprovechado del todo la
economía angoleña sigue rezagada a pesar
de las ambiciosas reformas como la
flotación de la moneda nacional y la
consolidación fiscal tras cinco años de
recesión en 2021 volvió el crecimiento
económico pero la inflación es hoy del
25% y la tasa de paro subió del 24 al 30
por ciento en sango a las afueras de
luanda christina está sin trabajo desde
marzo
desde que perdí mi trabajo es muy
difícil pagar el alquiler las tasas
escolares de los niños en la
electricidad es muy complicado porque mi
marido es el único que tiene trabajo y
su sueldo no alcanza para pagar todo
ahora mismo aún no hemos pagado el
alquiler
en 2017 el presidente joão lourenço fue
elegido con la promesa de realizar un
milagro económico diversificar la
economía y crear medio millón de puestos
de trabajo el gobierno culpa la pandemia
de los retrocesos pero para este
economista no es la única razón
angola es uno de los 20 peores países
para hacer negocios en el mundo no hay
ninguna infraestructura tenemos un
sistema educativo deficiente así que
mientras el estado se niega a abordar
estos problemas ya dejar que el sector
privado se encargue del resto no
podremos diversificar nuestra economía
estado rest pro sector privado no es no
vamos a diversificar el cual miren
angola el crudo sigue representando el
30 por ciento del pib y el 90 por ciento
de los ingresos por exportaciones
seguimos hablando de elecciones para
comentar las presidenciales que tuvieron
lugar el 9 de agosto en kenia para raila
odinga opositor de 77 años este fue el
quinto intento de llegar a la
presidencia sin éxito su rival el
vicepresidente saliente william ruto fue
declarado ganador por la comisión
electoral por un poco más de 230.000
votos sin embargo raila odinga impugnó
este resultado ante el más alto tribunal
del país ahora la justicia tiene dos
semanas para dirimir
hace poco presentamos con éxito nuestro
recurso a las elecciones presidenciales
ante el tribunal supremo de que en los
pasos que hemos dado se ajustan
plenamente a las disposiciones de
nuestra constitución sobre la resolución
de conflictos electorales
anderson lynn bledsoe discute y james
saber pib esto afirma nuestra profunda
creencia en la constitución el estado de
derecho y la resolución pacífica de los
conflictos incluidos los de alto riesgo
como las elecciones presidenciales
-hay sexuales that the presidential
elección por su parte el presidente
electo william bruto intentó calmar la
tensa situación del país tras el anuncio
de los resultados en particular hizo un
llamado a la unidad y a dejar atrás las
disputas prometió también que su futuro
gobierno estaría a la altura de las
enormes expectativas de los kenianos y
aseguró que rendiría cuentas sobre su
ejercicio político
aguanto promesas all the people of kenia
which way the bottle
te quiero prometer a todo el pueblo de
kenia sea cual sea su voto que este será
su gobierno sé que muchos se preguntan
especialmente a aquellos que han hecho
muchas cosas contra nosotros quiero
decirles que no tienen nada que temer
que no hay lugar para la venganza que no
hay lugar para mirar atrás de snow room
for looking back
si miramos hacia el futuro soy muy
consciente de que nuestro país se
encuentra en una fase en la que
necesitamos que todos se pongan manos a
la obra para seguir adelante where we
need org
inyectó tu móvil
[Aplausos]
apareció con un espectacular traje de
plumas negras el nuevo rey del pueblo
solo en sudáfrica un poderoso gobernante
tradicional fue coronado a pesar de una
feroz guerra de clanes ascendió al trono
ante miles de personas
en sudáfrica los líderes y jefes
tradicionales están reconocidos por la
constitución y son muy respetados por su
pueblo ya que juegan un papel importante
para mantener la paz social
el rito se celebró en gran secreto el
nuevo rey de los zulúes el gobernante
tradicional más poderoso de sudáfrica
fue coronado el sábado 20 de agosto en
este país africano con 11 lenguas
oficiales los gobernantes y jefes
tradicionales están reconocidos por la
constitución reyes sin poder ejecutivo
ejercen una profunda autoridad moral y
son venerados por su pueblo
hoy es un nuevo proceso muy importante
de la ascensión del rey es una ceremonia
tradicional en la que el rey reza y se
somete al rey fallecido y también
informa a los ancestros de que ahora hay
un nuevo rey es trico
para suceder a su padre goodwill
zwelithini fallecido en 2021 tras un
reinado de 50 años mi psuv su luz su luz
de 47 años fue coronado a la manera
tradicional en el palacio de quad que
tan tan da yo en nongoma una pequeña
ciudad de la provincia suroriental de
kwazulu-natal y cuna del mayor grupo
étnico de sudáfrica la coronación no
contó con el apoyo unánime de la familia
real hijo de la favorita del difunto rey
ni su solo sulú está siendo desafiado
por la primera esposa y sus
descendientes
el nuevo rey se ha pronunciado al
respecto
sé que están al tanto del estado de la
familia real en los últimos tiempos pero
que todo lo que oigan en los medios de
comunicación y los comentarios que hacen
los que se disputan el trono los oigan
pero no los escuché encendiendo son
fustiga en la noche
además de la corona la riqueza del rey
también está en el centro de la disputa
el rey zulú es un rico terrateniente
posee casi 30.000 kilómetros cuadrados y
cerca de 1500 propiedades en los
próximos meses el presidente de cyril
ramaphosa sellar a la coronación
reconociendo formalmente al rey su luz
con la esperanza de poner fin a las
rivalidades que amenazan la paz en el
reino el petróleo un festival anual para
preservar conmemorar y honrar la
herencia y las tradiciones africanas de
colombia tiene lugar anualmente en la
ciudad de cali nuestra enviada especial
le ayuda él estuvo allí y se reunió con
algunos de los protagonistas del
festival para hablar de los vínculos con
el continente africano
tras dos años de pandemia el festival
afro más importante de latinoamérica
está de vuelta a su formato original en
las calles de la ciudad de cali en
colombia el festival de música del
pacífico petronio álvarez quien mortal
hizo el nombre del músico folclórico de
buenaventura
petronio álvarez quintero durante 5 días
de baile música moda gastronomía y
artesanías los paisajes del pacífico
colombiano se trasladan a las calles de
esta ciudad vibrando al ritmo de un
instrumento con raíces africanas la
marimba la hermana latina del balafón
oiga aumentar los africanos que llegaron
aquí esclavizados
cuando encontraron la materia prima que
los aplique en su país y en su tierra
entonces tuvieron que reformar o adecuar
un poco la marimba con las materias
primas y encontrar una caja porque la
marimba es tan importante bueno la
marimba
es el instrumento que ha exorcizado todo
esto es el dolor de los negros
esclavizados y llegaron a casa
es la marimba que le permitió a la gente
recordar y traer memoria de su fábrica
fábrica materna gastronomía artesanía
moda los vínculos entre el pacífico
colombiano y el continente africano se
manifiestan de manera evidente en el
petróleo una conexión que los artistas
sienten también como nos contó la
cantante ninja góngora bueno quiero
decirles que tengo muchos amigos de
áfrica
ahorita mismo
un proyecto
el baterista
legales y en bajista es de camerún
tenemos una hermandad hermosa muy muy
bien hay un amigo mío de argelia que se
llama llamen cádiz es como mi hermanito
normalizado digo que tenemos en colombia
cuando vi a mi mamá digo te pareces a
las mujeres de mi país y
somos familia porque
son la herencia ese legado que llevo
aquí en el pacífico colombiano no son
los artistas quieren fortalecer los
vínculos entre los dos continentes
anna copete de la directora del festival
nos explicó el papel que tiene el
petróleo en este acercamiento hace rato
nosotros estamos procurando tener unos
vínculos mucho más fuertes con otros
festivales afro centrados de
latinoamérica y de áfrica de hecho este
año participamos en el festival de las
artes escénicas y de la música de costa
de marfil en marzo donde pudimos llevar
todo el conocimiento y llevar toda la
promoción del festival por supuesto los
directores que estuvieron en ese mercado
que eran de todo el continente africano
se quedaron sorprendido porque muchos no
conocían que colombia había un
africanidad tan viva como la que tenemos
en el pacífico colombiano y había un
festival que promovía es africanidad y
que trataba y que trata de preservarla y
de cuidarla y creo que ya dijimos el
primer vínculo para comenzar a estrechar
relaciones
a nosotros como diáspora nos interesa
muchísimo poder tener ese puente de
diálogo y de intercambio con diferentes
festivales y diferentes mercados del
continente africano y el petróleo espera
invitar a un país africano para su
próxima edición así cerramos este
episodio de áfrica siete días gracias
por su sintonía nos vemos la próxima
semana
[Música]